[Music]
um hello you know what's crazy about
this year at Comic-Con tell me that it's
like a thousand degrees on the rest of
the planet and we're suffering from huge
global warming but where we're sitting
right now is actually a little chilly in
San Diego it makes no sense uh everybody
from Phoenix which is where I'm at that
just set a national record for the most
consecutive days of 110 or more will now
be moving over here and vacationing on
this Terrace so this is going to be now
a tourist trap where you and I are
sitting so we got here first yeah we're
the Pioneers but the thing is like
yesterday it wasn't chilly it's actually
like legit where we're sitting right now
there's like a wind tunnel yeah and it's
like but anyway listen man it's nice so
um I've told you this before and I'm
going to say it again
um I'm a big fan of your work I grew up
reading your work uh you had a real
impact on me in terms of where I'm at
now with collider just getting me into
the space reading comics just want to
thank you oh no well actually I I think
that there's not enough acknowledgment
going back the other way right and I did
this on a couple other interviews of
thanking people like you I I I think at
times that what people like you and what
your platform do gets taken for granted
especially when when you have things
like the pandemic then it really becomes
obvious to me the importance of what
your group does and now even here this
year with the lack of Hollywood right
there still needs to be
information coming out there still needs
to be fun we need to engage with fandom
regardless of what's happening at any
given time in the world and so I'm going
look at they're all going to come and
they're still going to put tons and tons
of news out there and yes it would be
fun to have more Hollywood news but you
know what that's not a reality
there's still a lot and you guys are
still doing your your job so I you guys
are a lifeblood to our industry too so
thank you well one of the things about
this year at Khan and I and I don't know
I mean you're on the convention floor
you have a booth maybe you can tell me
uh when I walked around on Wednesday
night and Thursday the floor was on
another level of crowded and it's
because there are less panels This Year
everyone is shopping this year in a way
that they I don't know if they've done
in the past no they're not in a line for
eight hours yeah right so they have to
reallocate their time and they're going
okay well I normally would be lining up
for Hall h or that big panel that's
going to be four hours of my day I've
already allocated that that's not
happening what am I doing during those
four hours I I keep saying I think that
there's an interesting
documentary autopsy to actually
interview all these people a lot of
people say okay I know you bought your
tickets hoping for the whole Hollywood
side it wasn't there tell us what you
did instead right and and just listen to
how they basically went well I I like
anime so I did more anime oh I like toys
I went over and did toy like maybe they
just slept more who knows no they're on
the convention floor buying exclusives
they're just shopping I got a bunch of
questions for you but let's go through
these okay
um in an emergency what are you saving
at your house because if you have like
three minutes to grab stuff besides your
family and pets sure okay they're out
they're out already they're already out
so what are the things that are in your
house like whether it be shoes toys
whatever it is uh that I'd be lamenting
that I didn't go back in and get
scorched a little bit for wow
um
Pro not not too many but uh I I used to
have all my high-graded books in the
house right my action number one and
stuff but my wife said you better get
that out of the house right I don't want
that in the house just in case somebody
knows it's in the house so I don't have
to save all my high creative books but
probably a couple things off the top is
uh I've got a
1971 Kellogg's baseball uh set these are
the cards you got out of the cereal box
you could only give them out of cereal
box there were 75 of them and you
couldn't send in box tops I have the
complete set all in PSA 10. I have the
top I have the actually I've got like
five sets on PSA that are number one but
if I only could save one I'd save the 71
uh baseball Kellogg set and then uh I'd
probably grab
I play like Sim games uh like board
games so I'd probably grab the 72
baseball season because that was when
Steve Carlton became my hero he's a
lefty I'm a lefty uh it's a dice rolling
game I probably grabbed one board game
right now my favorite board game is a
game called Imperial struggle I think
it's a genius chess game I I like chess
games
um and what else would I have to grab
out of there
probably the oh
I I I do have a uh a couple pieces of
artwork that I need to grab out of
that's right I have a couple of most of
the artwork someplace else but I do have
a couple pieces hanging on the wall I'd
have to grab uh who do you think should
be on the top of the the Mount Rushmore
of the comic book industry who's on the
Mount Rushmore for you and if you have
three or four people that you can put on
it uh well the the easy one for me is is
uh uh Jack Kirby and Stanley those are
one two but they're they're right there
um
probably have to put Simon Schuster just
because they began
this thing that is now here with us
right so you I I I again you don't have
to say they're the best artist the best
Storyteller you just have to go they
they put the first step on the moon
right
um so I put them up there and then
between sort of the beginning and and
the big boys
um
man who who also I think sort of has
climbed the mountain that high I
again now I'll get a little personal I I
think John busemma I think John busemma
did a giant body of work that was just
magnificent
um that was up there and if I had to put
somebody from today's world on there
then
I I'd probably
and this may seem a little bit biased
but I I put gray capullo and here's why
I say Greg I mean for modern and again
I'm I'm I'm arbitrarily picking one just
because the quality of his work and the
body of work and the deadline right so
Jim Lee is amazing and people say nice
things about me and I've got other
people but to do it for that long of a
time which is why I put John B semi
people who do a body of work for so long
I just I know how hard it is so I'm just
amazed at him which is part of Jack
Kirby
he's good here's his body of work so
body of work can be matter and then oh
by the way they draw really good so yeah
um how is the comic book industry gotten
better
since you started you've gotten worse
um gotten better easily is at the talent
level is way higher than when I broke in
right because back then
you know we're talking about the mid 80s
you either have to be in New York or in
that vicinity to send it so it was
essentially whoever was the best artist
that had the attitude that lived within
a thousand miles in New York in North
America right and mostly America
um
now that we've opened it up with the
internet and people can post their
artwork and you can now find global
artists right all those people that were
discovered because they were in a
basement in Ohio 35 40 years ago they're
now globally right so I have people now
that work for me from Poland and Korea
and Russia and Spain and Mexico so I
mean I grab from all over the world I
think that's magnificent so again the
competition is really high because it's
it's it's amazing the the downside of
that I would assume uh as a young kid is
it now the competition is really tough
so before like I look at what the way
they draw now I go man if I could draw
like you with my hustle you think I'm
doing good now I would I'd be up by the
moon right now
but there's so many people that are
great
that that they get lost in it right and
so it to me it's like all these great
artists that are not to me getting their
due
um that are there and then
and then I think even here I think
there's a little bit of enticement of
going to conventions and doing sketches
and just doing covers and just doing
like these one-offs making money and I
get it everybody's got to feed their
baby and you got to do it
but I don't think long term it builds a
career it makes money and it gives you a
little bit of reputation it doesn't
build a career and it doesn't turn you
into a potential brand so it's hard for
me to find people that want to do
interior artwork and do bodies of work
sure you you have a very successful toy
company and you've done a lot of cool
stuff what's the IP that you would
you're still dying to get your hands on
uh it's actually a bigger it's a bigger
answer than that the theory is in my
head isn't that there's one I'd like to
do it's that I think
I should if I could write every contract
and toys
that that the last paragraph on every
contract no matter who gets it right
Hasbro Mattel Playmates uh everybody
else
the last paragraph says and with this
property McFarland toys gets to do one
figure
because then I'll get to do my one Star
Wars and my one Transformers and my one
Marvel and my one whatever's the hot one
I could do one just to say this is what
it would look like if you gave me the
contract right uh and and pass it on
because yeah I just I look at a lot of
stuff go man just come here come on just
one right uh but that's it I am waiting
have you tried because I know the
license is impossible and I ask this of
everyone and maybe my asking this will
bring it into existence okay
um the the big thing that fans want is
Blade Runner and it never gets made
because because the license is just so I
guess complicated or I don't know what
the reason is but have you tried for
Blade Runner
um I would be surprised if we haven't I
don't know off top my head why we didn't
get it but
um I've been told no
hundreds if not thousands of times and
usually what we do so I'll go back and
look at that one is uh by the way I
would love it if you were like wait
there's I can make some you know what I
mean yeah yeah so what has historically
happened with us is that we go and ask
and if they say no then there's usually
two reasons it's no because we don't
want to do it we think toys are schmalty
or because somebody already has the
license right those are the two the one
where it's like out you know we think
toys are Smarty And or there's a
complication then we go well okay what
if we come back in two months and and
you come back and you come back and you
come back let me tell you earlier when I
was making toys the people at Apple
records said we will never license a
Beatles toy Todd stop asking so I just
kept asking and eventually they went
fine but it's got to look like an
animation right it has to be Yellow
Submarine right but that's better than
no I got him I got him away from a no
Jimi Hendrix was the same way they're
like
gonna Sully his reputation with a
plastic toy whatever and I kept trying
to show them what it would look like and
it would I think it would be cool
whatever and then eventually they went
oh I could because they they're thinking
of like a 4.99 toy from when they were a
kid in the aisles and they're projecting
right just like people who don't
understand comics and you say comic
books they think of Archie and Superman
because that's what they did when they
were eight right and they don't know
there's now this whole Litany of titles
that basically has a wide range just
like the movies and TVs they go to what
do you think McFarland toys has made a
lot of toys what do you consider your
top three in terms of you know what I
mean like are there three that you just
like oh my God I love these These are
these are just great
um so let me see off top my head because
I don't really have one that's a burner
but there's an amalgamation of some
right and so to me when I was making
toys they kept saying you can't do that
you can't do that even sometimes my own
Factory no you can't do that won't work
and so I would just go well let's just
try it like I want to see with my eyes
it doesn't work and then it would work
and I go guys so
um I remember we used to do grooves uh
grooves in the baseball players for
Pinstripes and then we'd have to do a
wash I thought it looked clunky and it
was messy and then I go why can't we
just Temple the the the pinstripes on
and they went yeah but we can't get all
the way through the wrinkles and all and
this is why when you go over to China
that when they say no it's because they
can't make it perfect and I keep trying
to tell them I'll take 90 percent 90 of
cool is still pretty cool and so when
they finally did one were they right
some deep folds they couldn't get the
Pinstripes into the machine couldn't get
into yes but it looked 10 times better
than the other way right I'm like guys
so I go okay so there's certain ways you
can tampo I remember we did one hockey
player where the folds on the on the uh
Jersey I think was Brett Hall I go
that's how I want to see fault I turned
to my sculptors one time we we did hair
on a few email and the grooves were like
twice as much as we did and it held up
and I went guys we can now start doing
hair that thin they said no we can oh by
the way
we can do 200 paint applications on it
and still get it within budget and then
probably the one that sort of rounded it
out for me was we I think it was the
Mandarin spawn
and the Mandarin spawn had all this
super detail on it and super sort of
sophisticated painting and they all went
Todd get ready get ready for a
disappointment
and when it came I went
shoot that held up pretty like so that's
your disappointment then let's do a lot
of disappointing toys from now on so
it's interesting where everybody else's
head is and here's why in the toy
industry when you go over to China
they have been beaten for decades that
everything has to be perfect and clean
there it's like every Uno chip has to be
exact you can't miss the dots you can't
have any smudges on it and they have
been beaten Relentless and I come over
there and I go hey I want to make a toy
that looks like it's been underneath the
couch for like two months and it's all
grungy and it's all dirty and they get
nervous because they think that if they
do that you're not going to pay them
because they're used to Perfection so if
you're doing splatters they can't
replicate splatters
I don't care that means everyone's gonna
have a different splatter awesome and
they get they get fidgety and I go no I
want you to do a rub on it and it's like
and they're going well it won't be
exactly the same exactly the same
they're they're they've been so used to
replicating by the way it totally makes
sense from their perspective though yeah
because this is how you typically do it
right no no and I get it but when I said
guys here's what we're gonna do I'm
gonna write a letter that says no matter
what did they turn out I will pay you
your bill so you're getting your money
no matter what I just need you to do
this and sometimes I'd have to drag them
across the line to do it and then they
do it and they go oh my gosh look at all
this and then they would take my toys
and go get more business and all of a
sudden they go get more business from a
Japanese company and then they'd kick me
out because I go ah you're not giving us
enough order stuff and so they would
take my blueprint and then kick me out a
little bit later
um spawn has been popular for I want I I
apologize was it 92 it came out correct
so yeah we're year 31. right so what do
you think it is because sometimes
characters don't stand the test of time
what has it been what do you think it is
about spawn that so many people love it
for so long
well you know what so let's just start
with the 31 years right it's hard for me
to imagine that if you take any
character and you're just dogged and you
go I'm gonna do it regardless of sort of
the Ebbs and the flows for 31 years
eventually you get when you get when you
get sort of the upticks people go oh
yeah I tried that's that thing that's
been around now 10 20 15. I mean like
the time does matter they people now
know it's not going away right so they
just got to accept it so now if given
it's part of the mythology of superhero
comic books now right I mean if you're
essentially 37 38 because you probably
didn't remember from one to five uh uh
in your age that there you've never
spent one day that you remember where
spawn doesn't exist that was a world I
lived in in my head with Superman Batman
Spider-Man or whatever else so if they
just were always there I just gave them
credit that they were valuable so time
matters I can't seem to get this across
to creators enough I just had a
conversation with somebody yesterday so
that matters then if you can then take
that and put story and content in there
that people like and if I was to do a
word cloud of Spawn I think the two
biggest words would be dark badass cool
right I mean I think that would be it
and maybe Cape off and change off in the
corner but I think just he's just a
badass dude and I think people respond
to that not only with my character but
with any badass character that's out
there whether it's Marvel DC or anybody
else I think people just like characters
that push back and aren't aren't Boy
Scouts you are and I apologize for not
knowing the exact details but you did or
are doing that do the evolution 25th
anniversary great video what can you say
about it well again it came out 25 years
ago sort of on Lark I remember getting a
call out of the blue from Eddie Vedder
which is always a sort of a weird phone
call right by the way I am a huge Pearl
Jam fan I wouldn't know what that's like
no I'm not right but it's just like Todd
Eddie Vedder I'm like
huh from Pearl Jam
oh hi Eddie like okay Eddie uh good
talking to you too
um anyways what was happening is that
they wanted at that time the the record
album
the record label was bugging them to do
another music video oh I remember and
and they were resistant because that's
just who they are right this is awesome
they're a group that doesn't want to be
on camera right they're like no we gotta
do a music video we don't want to be in
our music video that was their whole
goal uh and he said hey I've been
watching the HBO animated show
we now know how we can do this we'll
just animate it I got a song called Do
The Evolution uh it's about all time
space and dimension we need to do all
that in three minutes are you up for the
task right so I'm going time space
intervention so from the beginning to
the end of time three minutes let's do
it seems it seems like we can pull this
off
um and then and then the thing that blew
my mind out of that initial sort of
getting set up he said I'm going to send
you something that just sort of gives
you my vibe and I went yeah okay cool
and I thought he was going to send me a
wreck his soundtrack or he's gonna send
me something or example and what he did
was I get the the very next day I get
this thing in the mail and it's a VHS of
my spawn HBO show edited to his song to
The Evolution
and so I could see sort of the tempo and
I I wish I had it because it was super
cool I just went that's wicked oh hey
Eddie uh who who did that I did it Todd
no no but who who edited this I did that
you edited that yeah
you have an editing machine at home yes
I do I have an avid you
okay so rock and rollers get famous so
they can get money so they can buy
editing machines I I I guess I thought
you guys did different stuff with your
cash right but uh so he was he was
really into the process so that even at
the end when we actually did the video
at the end he was like hey Todd were off
because they were touring hey we're off
tour is it okay if I come into the
editing with you guys and help you edit
it
it's your video you can do whatever you
want the answer is yes and he's really
good and he's smart and there's a lot of
things right even to The Bitter End if
you watch that that uh video the last
sound you hear you don't hear it all the
time because they cut it but the last
sound you hear is crickets
right it's basically Lights Out it's
over right but he put the cricket he's
going what if we put the cricket sounds
in there like just out of the blue like
uh we're just going to fade the block
there's nothing but then we put it in
and we went
okay if everything's dead
theoretically show would be the Crickets
but it just sounded so cool that it was
like everything's still at night and
that's all you hear and so we kept in it
and he was doing that throughout the
whole video so there's touches of him
throughout the the silly funny story
real quickly on that one was every day
he came into the edding bay he was
bringing a briefcase
briefcase briefcase briefcase didn't
seem like what rock and rollers did and
then he'd leave and I go you got another
meeting no I'm going home the next day
he'd come with the briefcase put it down
and go hey you going to another meeting
no going home and you never open up the
briefcase
and on the third fourth day of the
editing because we're getting near the
end I curiously said hey Eddie uh which
don't mind me asking I'm not prying what
like why are you bringing that briefcase
every day if you're just going home and
he goes oh my gosh Todd I didn't think
you were going to ever ask and then I I
went and I still to this day go well
what if I didn't and he walked over and
goes cluck click and he opens it up and
there's two brand new glove baseball
gloves because he's a baseball freak two
brand new baseball gloves and a baseball
and he goes you want to play catch this
afternoon and I want I go what he goes I
heard you went to college playing
baseball yes I played back then baseball
he goes I know I hear you good and he's
a baseball freak you want to play catch
Point catcher that event it's super cool
there happened to be an unseasonably
heat wave that day it was about 107 and
in in Southern California Eddie classic
just black boots black pants black shirt
black leather jacket
and he's smoking as he's playing catch
I am telling you and of course you know
how Macho Man right are it's like it's
getting hotter and hotter I'm from
Phoenix I'm like a cockroach I'm not I'm
I'm not giving in to Eddie it's getting
hot but I'm like you Eddie I got
this and then he's like oh yeah
and then I could see that I go
I I think he's going to pass out I drink
but he would not have given up and I
want Eddie
you want to take a break
if you do
and I knew I'd go the answers I better
give him no no no no I'm a bit hot and
he's like yeah okay fine me too and then
he went
and I go if I hadn't if I had just been
a little more Macho there was a
possibility I could have killed any
better that day or at least giving him a
heat streak so but a heat stroke uh that
day but anyways I I don't know if he
would have ever opened up the briefcase
that day if I had I would have asked him
on the first day I couldn't have made it
to 30. listen I want to ask you
something I just thought he was going to
a meeting yeah I have a so there's a big
I know you're a huge obviously uh you
sports collectibles but it's really in
the last year or two taking off with
these box breaks these live box breaks
searching for like one-offs and trying
to strike gold what is your take on this
whole box break and the the sports
collectible industry leaning into all
this well what
I would put
uh it's collectible
the category of any Collectibles right
there there's no one way to say that's
the right way to collect right I don't
think it's sort of like religion a
little bit like believe whatever you
want right so if that's how you get your
joy
of collecting doing it that way and at
work and there's enough people to
support that
knock yourself knock yourself out might
not be my cup of tea I'm over here
collecting a different way but it
doesn't mean that the way that I
collected the way that you collect is
better or worse than the way anybody
else is doing it's like listening to
music you listen to your music and enjoy
it you don't have to listen to the music
I enjoy so collecting to me I think is
is almost like tasting food we all have
our own palette of what's interesting to
me the only thing in Collectibles that
I'm that my antennas up on is one I
think some people on our side that have
the product that are just a little bit
of hucksters and are taking advantage
knowingly of our consumer right and and
I I think if you just treat people
fairly and and price things fairly then
you'll have fans forever right I want to
ask you something real fast because I'm
out of time do it do you think because
the box break the thing about searching
for like the the really rare card now I
understand the appeal you're you're
gambling yeah and do a little bit of
Willy Wonka my question is do you think
the the live box break and what they're
doing can be applied to the toy industry
and comic books in a way where you're
buying like um five toys and you know
what I mean like and and you're opening
the box hoping that you're gonna get
this super rare thing or you're you're
buying a bunch of comics and you're
hoping to get this graded 9.9 whatever
yeah of these new things do you think
this is applicable yeah the answer is
yes um on the toy front
um where it's applicable is that you
know we've done like Chase figures and
these rare figures and whatever else and
sometimes the uh the actual customers
don't really get a chance at them
because very clever stock boys of course
and people work in the back room who are
the ones that opened them up have the
knowledge or at least even if they don't
collect that specifically but they do
have to know they're able to peel them
off prior to it ever getting out so if
you could create sealed cases that had
that opportunity and it never went
through the normal channel so that's
what I mean though specifically is that
like say McFarland toys was creating
like the you know cases of and I know we
have to wrap but like you're you're
creating five toys and you're selling it
directly to Consumer the way that
they're selling these these exactly if
you did it right if you did a direct
answers yes if you had somebody who you
trust that had a Keen Eye that says hey
I'm going to open up a box and I'm going
to only peel out what I see because I'm
I'm I'm a pro I'm going to peel out what
I think is but the best possible nine
nine potential if this got graded right
that's the one we're going to sell right
here this uh this whole case there are
two books that if it was my own money
I'm the pronoun I would send these two
books in because I know what these look
like right uh yes I think I think it's
applicable
on that note sir I could have asked you
another thousand questions but let's do
that next year at Comic-Con uh Todd
thank you so much for coming in yeah I
appreciate you giving me the time and
again thanks thanks to everything you do
in your platform I really appreciate you
being here uh everyone thank you